[Music]
we all deal with conflict whether it's
with loved ones or people who are not so
loved
conflict is a fact of life but doesn't
mean that you need to flail your way
through it
hi i'm rich burnett for one dream in
this episode of perspectives three
experts look at what research shows
about conflict specifically between
partners
they also provide some tools that anyone
can use to make conflict more manageable
and productive
we begin now with the first of these
tools
simply taking a pause
enjoy
[Music]
the stable partnership is for many
people the most consistent source of
both support and potential relationship
stress and the overall picture of that
relationship has a profound impact on
psychological and emotional health
a study of married couples from the
university of utah used ct scans to
assess heart attack risk based on the
presence of calcium deposits in the
coronary arteries
those calcium deposits narrow the
arteries and increase heart attack risk
interestingly what mattered more than
the presence of calcium deposits in
predicting heart attack risk was the
emotional tone
of the marital relationship
all of the couples in the study had
conflict
for women it wasn't the amount of
arguing or even the degree of the
arguments that predicted health it was
whether there was any affection
expressed in the relationship
a lack of warmth predicted heart attack
risk
for the men arguing didn't predict risk
to their health but power struggles for
control did
the couples in the study were all
relatively happy generally healthy and
with long-standing marriages the couples
in the study had been married for an
average of 36 years
but some of the couples in the study had
conflict styles that were literally
doing damage to their hearts
this is consistent with ongoing research
by dr john gottman dr gottman's research
has consistently found that it's not the
presence of conflict but rather the
absence of affection that predicts
marital failure
sometimes in a relationship setting
limits means realizing that we're caught
in conflict and then agreeing together
to stop
research in dr gottman's relationship
lab found that when couples were arguing
taking a 20-minute break to stop talking
and just read a magazine helped both
members of the couple calm down their
heart rates returned to normal
after the break the tone of the
discussion shifted and the couples
expressed higher levels of affection and
humor
this is helpful because a more positive
style of interaction is more conducive
to resolving conflict and finding a
mutually agreeable solution
gottman and his collaborators have
become quite famous for being able to
predict with greater than 90 accuracy
which marriages will last and which will
end in divorce
in their studies gottman's research team
almost always collects a lot of data
they recruit couples to come into their
research center and subject them to a
wide range of tests there are many
questionnaires video and audio
recordings participants are often hooked
up to devices that record their
physiological responses to things blood
pressure heart rate muscle tension a lot
of things like that
a key part of the procedures that they
use is to have the two members of the
couple have a conversation in which they
discuss something that's been a point of
disagreement in their relationship
in essence gottman asks them to engage
in a bit of a conflict to have at least
a little bit of an argument
a typical government study involves
collecting all of this data and then
waiting in some cases several years
after this time interval some of the
participants are still married
others have divorced the research team
then analyzes their data to see if there
was anything in those records that was
consistently present for the still
married couples that was not there for
the now divorced couples they also do
the reverse
turns out there's several things that
are present for the divorced couples
that's only rarely present for the still
married couples
the important factors are a few key
features of how they argue
now all couples argue okay i've talked
to a few people who've been married for
decades who claim that they've never
argued i'm not sure if i believe them
actually regardless no one's been
following them around with a camera to
confirm that data one way or the other
almost all romantic partners argue even
romantic partners who are extremely
happy in their relationship
a bad way to start an argument is with
blame and harsh criticism
imagine one partner starts by expressing
something like the problem is that he
doesn't want to spend time with the
family he just spends all of his time
working
several things will happen if the
argument begins this way
first the blood pressure heart rate and
skin conductance levels of the recipient
of the criticism will rise
his cognitive function will decline as
his fight-or-flight system is activated
if this next thing happens
gottman almost doesn't need to collect
any more data
if the recipient of the criticism rolls
his eyes
if he looks away and is basically
dismissive of the criticism
then this discussion is already doomed
and the marriage may be also
in addition to the eye rolling there are
many other conflict-related behaviors
that seem to lead to a downward spiral
of negativity in a close relationship
the most important tip that gottman's
research has ever yielded is the
following
if you want to maintain a lasting
romantic relationship learn to argue
without being sarcastic overly critical
or dismissive of your partner
gottman and his colleagues have
repeatedly found that marital arguments
discussions that involve a
gentle startup lead to better outcomes
an argument with a gentle startup
specifically avoids assigning blame
so instead of saying the problem is that
he doesn't want to spend time with his
family
he just spends all of his time working
gottman's research suggests the
discussion should begin with something
like
i feel unhappy that he doesn't spend
more time with the family i wish that we
could find a way he could spend more
time with us even though i understand
that might involve taking some time away
from work
the same information is conveyed the
same desires but without the blame part
now if the recipients still rolls the
eyes or is generally dismissive the
problem is likely to still persist
gottman would likely predict divorce
but not as confidently as he might have
more importantly if arguments and
discussions begin this way gottman has
found that they tend to become more
productive
the arguments become less upsetting
group problem-solving activities is what
they turn into rather than a session
primarily about venting frustrations
now i've described this as something
that's the fault of the person who
started the discussion but it's clear
from gottman's work that this isn't the
case that's not how it works
arguments don't exist in a vacuum they
don't exist in isolation it's often the
case that the aggressive start to an
argument happens because the partner has
been dismissive of the discussion in the
past
there's a point to be made here that
just because one argument starts
aggressively doesn't mean that a
marriage is doomed to divorce
gottman's research group might only
assess one argument but it's the
patterns that emerge from many arguments
that are the inherent problem
the key tip here is to learn to argue
better
to not be afraid of or defensive about
arguments and disagreements in general
being a better listener can lead to much
better problem solving
george bernard shaw tells us that the
single biggest problem with
communication is the illusion that it's
taken place
it's tongue-in-cheek but it's true
miscommunication occurs regularly and
drives a lot of conflict
there's been much written and studied
about differences in how men and women
communicate we know that men spend about
two-thirds of social conversations
talking about themselves men are less
likely to pick up on emotional cues
they're less likely to take turns or to
give openings to someone else men report
and women engage in rapport talk of
course much of this was summarized and
made popular by john gray men are from
mars women are from venus or by deborah
tannen you just don't understand
but how do we go about assessing
communication of course we have
self-report surveys we have interviews
we might use reports from others or we
might even use observational studies
another methodology uses trigger tape
studies where you watch a stimulus and
then you have to generate a response
the interpersonal communication skills
test assesses five categories of key
skills
insightfulness
verbal expression
assertiveness
listening skills
and emotional management a sort of road
map to the essential competencies to
having a healthy emotionally intelligent
conversation
here's a few sample items from that
survey rated on a one to five scale i
managed to express my ideas clearly i
find it easy to see things from someone
else's point of view
people don't get what i'm saying
or i have difficulty putting my thoughts
into words
now we think that there are five basic
requisites for discussions of emotions
so first you have to be able to access
your emotions so you can't communicate
your emotion if you're in denial say
about it
you need the verbal communication skills
to talk about your emotions there needs
to be a necessary level of self-esteem i
have a right to feel and to pursue my
own goals there needs to be a safe
environment and of course you need to
have a willing and able partner
how could we go about improving
communication skills and of course we
have two people we have the sender or
the talker and we have the listener we
need to pick a good time for the
conversation you need to clearly express
what you need and to make it clear
having realistic expectations sticking
with one issue at a time and being aware
of your own and the other person's
verbal and non-verbal signals
if you're the listener we need to work
on things such as eliminating
distractions improving nonverbal cues
improving verbal cues and using empathic
statements
drawing from the couple's emotion
regulation research of bob levinson and
others we see that higher marital
satisfaction is associated with less
suppression of negative emotions
when someone expresses anger at you your
brain is good at finding connections to
word and actions that are related to
anger things like yelling
it can be very hard to think of
something to say or do that is related
to nice
just because anger is so firmly
activated in your brain
but if you do think of those words those
words and actions if you can respond to
aggression with nice behaviors it can
often defuse a negative interaction
often very rapidly
researchers refer to this shift away
from complementarity as
non-complementarity it's hard to do but
it can be very effective
i have like most people occasionally
been in unpleasant arguments arguments
that grew quickly too angry or acerbic
to be productive any longer
in these situations we might be hurling
insults or shouting at each other but
not actually listening to each other
anymore
at this point the argument was really of
no value
information was being conveyed but no
information was actually being received
no progress was being made toward
actually resolving the disagreement
my human brain like everyone else's has
a hard time getting out of the rut of
this nasty complementarity behavior
here's a trick that's worked for me
as you look at the person think i love
you over and over again don't say it now
just think the words i love you i love
you i love you even if you don't
actually love the person it can be
downright impossible to think of more
nasty things to say while you're doing
this as something positive does come to
mind say or do that positive thing it
might just end the conflict and get you
both onto something more pleasant and
productive
family counselors often use this
strategy when dealing with couples who
are having relationship problems
if two people argue aggressively with
one another a lot over an extended
period of time in particular the
aggression response will be stimulated
even before that first word of a
discussion is uttered the brain gets
into a defensive posture even before any
actual attack
once the two people in a relationship
are stuck in this mode of processing it
can be very hard to find a way to live
happily
if one ideally both but even just one of
the members of this couple periodically
expresses something positive to the
other person it can help to break this
vicious cycle
it can be an uncomfortable thing to do
actually we're talking here about
delivering a compliment or a favor that
is undeserved seemingly unwarranted and
yet as much as possible completely
genuine
researchers like myrna friedlander and
her colleagues have found that the
technique is often helpful
the one potential problem that she's
identified with this approach is that if
the compliment is taken as not being
genuine perhaps taken as a sarcastic
statement rather than a compliment that
it can lead back to more aggressive
interactions
if you choose to try this technique then
you should start by finding something to
do or say that you can be genuine about
then be sure to follow through to make
clear that you did actually mean what
you said or did
i've urged you to experiment with being
nice to someone who well doesn't
necessarily deserve it someone who has
been mean or aggressive with you
i'm not really urging that you do it for
that person however but for yourself
if you can find a way to force yourself
momentarily to be kind to someone even
if they don't deserve that kindness you
can shift how their brain processes
additional incoming information
you can avoid for yourself the
unpleasant experience of an angry
confrontation and ultimately you can
have a greater influence on that other
person's behavior
[Music]
hey thanks for watching if you'd like to
learn more about the topics in this
episode the full list of series that
these clips came from is in the
description below you can watch them all
on one dream and don't forget to
subscribe to this youtube channel for
new episodes of perspectives and you can
watch previous ones here